well welcome back I'm joined by the
editors of the new Anthology poetry for
the many but they're rather unlikely
anthologist former labor leader Jeremy
Corin and former unite General Secretary
Len mcclusky but welcome to both of you
I certainly wasn't expecting you to to
grace my studio so thank you for coming
in um right Jeremy let me start with you
you were at this march on Saturday and
you were speaking there and as you know
it was a controversial March uh I from
my point I think a lot of people there
are there for the right reasons they're
there because they genuinely believe
that they want to have a ceasefire in
Gaza and stop more people being killed I
understand that but there are people
there and we've seen all the images all
over social media who are blatant
anti-semites and in some cases blatantly
supporting Hamas what do you feel about
that well they weren't taking part in
the March that was organized by PSC and
stop the war well they were there
well well there've been I've seen them
SE
the equivalent of the crowd of 10 Cup
finals came to London on Saturday to
March for peace in Gaza because they're
appalled at what's happening there and
there were people there who wanted
ceasefire there was but what about the
on blackards there calling the release
I've already said that calling for the
release of I've acknowledged that I'm
concerned about the ones who were
chanting death to the Jews the ones who
were wearing Hamas regalia the ones who
were chanting have been arrested by the
police every protest that's ever taken
place in London and I've been on many of
them always there a group of people
there to cause trouble they're normally
dealt with by the police don't be asking
Jeremy or the people who organized a
perfectly legitimate why should ask
somebody who helped organize it no he
didn't help organize speaker he was a
speaker all right well let me ask you
this so he's answered emphatically
should have been arrested you agree if
they're breaking the law and showing
illegal signs then obviously the police
have to act so anybody who can I just
let me just let me just ask you a simple
question you seem to be over concerned
with with anti-Semitism no no I did not
don't put words in my mouth I didn't say
that what I said was about to say was
you seem to be minimizing the fact that
800,000 people one of the very biggest
demonstr in our history well 300,000
okay well I'm minimizing your
description of the size of the crow but
I'm not minimizing as I said that
extends from Battery to AR but I said I
said at the start the majority of people
there were for their for
well-intentioned reasons right but he
was but they what do you want P do you
want us to say that anybody engaged in
anti-Semitism we can Dam out of hand
because we've been doing that both of us
all our lives what was interesting Lear
was that you were emphatic that you said
they should all be arrested do you
Jeremy think they should all be ARR
broken the law and the police feel
there's a case for it then of course
they can do that and they did do that in
some cases but I want you to understand
the size of this demonstration the
peaceful nature of it a very large
number of Jewish people in the Jewish
block also carrying placards calling for
the release of hostages this was a cry
of all kinds of people Jewish Muslim
Hindu Buddhist Christian everything
calling for an urgent ceasefire I think
the question you should be asking is why
hasn't our government listened to what
ordinary people are saying well because
they don't agree that there should be
BC's fire and there are I think a very
arguable points about that which we're
going to come to previous guest says you
haven't condemned what herass did on
October the 7th have you of course I
have on every speech and do you
unreservedly condemn at every speech
I've made I've utterly condemned the
killing of October the 7th and it was a
taking of innocent life it was totally
wrong under any circumstances you don't
bring back the tragedy of those, 1400
deaths by killing 10,000 people in Gaza
you have to have a process that leads to
a ceasefire that hopefully how do you
get do you think hamash should stay in
charge of the Palestinians to decide
who's in what your opinion wait a minute
I'll I'll tell you how you get rid of a
mass dead easy get the Israeli
government to comply with international
law withdraw from the occupied
territories dismantle illegal
settlements and build a viable Palestine
which is the United Nations position
it's the British government's position
it's the Amer why would that stop Hamas
behaving because there would not be a
need for Hamas the the what justifies
what they did nothing justifies disce
there a bunch of medieval barbarians it
was disgraceful but they're not going to
listen to any Reon it's interesting it's
interesting their Charter is a
nihilistic view of Israel and getting
interesting it's interesting that you
always have on the screens like many
other media the war between Israel and
Mass it's not a war between Israel and
the mass it's between Israel and the
Palestinian people but it's not
thousands and thousands so you agree
with thousands of people women and
children being killed no I don't agree
with 1500 being killed on October the 7
neither do I but but I do agree let me
explain what I do agree with can I put
let me explain to you I put something
let me just clarify my position it might
be helpful I've had lots of pro
Palestinian guests on the show as you
may or may not be aware very good I
tried to be very fair but I've been
consistent about my own opinion I think
after what Hamas did on October the 7th
it is utterly inconceivable that Hamas
remain in power in Gaza inconceivable
support amass I'm not aend of amas I
don't age you used to call them friends
no hang on we did no K let's get this
clear we did
say can you hang on a second let me just
is that not true can I say something
very clearly to which I've said many
times and I said it on Andrew Mah two
weeks ago 10 years ago 10 years ago I
was in a private meeting in the House of
Commons with a number of people who were
representative of different Palestinian
groups it was an attempt to understand
their views and to bring people together
for a short time a person who was
related to Hamas left the room and I
said in a Collegiate friendly and
appropriate way as you would at any
meeting where is our friend from Mass
gone that's all I said and that so you
called her as friends no oh come on well
come on peers you just you just admitted
how many times have you sat in a meeting
and called somebody a friend I wouldn't
say my friends from the IRA I wouldn't
say my friend from Isis I wouldn't say
my friend from Al-Qaeda you sent my
friends from Mass you might have Jeremy
you might have changed your mind which
you're perfectly entitled to do and my
understanding is you you do not regret
what you you are obsessed obsessed with
titl tattle of Politics on something
that happens 10 years ago why don't you
why don't you instead con people
supporting herass let me finish give me
a chance really let me yeah give me a
chance let me finish how do you think
people in Palestine feel under
occupation how do you think it's like
what it's like growing growing up with a
soldier outside your house how do you
feel how would you feel your land was
being taken put in how would you feel if
your children were being bombed in a
hospital can I answer yeah please okay I
had a Palestinian doctor on here a few
days ago who'd lost over 30 members of
his family right he grew up on the a
jabili refugee camp his parents were
displaced in 1948 and they ended up in
the refugee camp where he then lost
three of his daughters were killed in
isra strike on a homie who finally got
for himself he then immigrated and has
now been nominated for the Nobel Peace
Prize he was in tears at this desk in
that seat so I don't need to be told I
I've I've said I've said that the way
the way that Israel is able even today
to turn the tap on of water and energy
and fuel into Gaza is wrong Palestinians
should have the same human rights as
people in Israel I'm unequivocal about
that but I'm also unequivocal in my head
that Hamas has to go the question for
you Len and for you Jeremy but the
question is if Israel doesn't do it like
they're doing it how do they get rid of
give you the answer a ter I you I I no
no no no Pier I give you the answer
before and I'm I'm going to ask you a
question do you condemn the Israeli
government for the occupied settlements
that are growing and have been growing
for decades and are against
international law do you condemn that
yes fine then the best way to get rid of
any extremism that exists in Nations and
groups is to comply with international
law and make certain that Palestine is
given a VI and I'll finish with this
question if we all believe in a
two-state solution why doesn't our
government recognized the state of
Palestine why did they only recognize
the state of Israel I think you can only
have a
hypocrisy could only have a two-state
solution but in this particular part of
this very long conflict you have a
situation where Hamas now represents an
existential threat to Israel and they've
repeated it last week their spokesman
from Hamas repeatedly said when he was
challenge we want to do this again and
again and again again let me ask Jeremy
a question come I want to come back to
this thing about what do you do what do
you do to with Hamas do you keep them in
power you Israel claiming it is not from
him he agrees with the the Israeli
government you would answer I said would
you keep himass in power you wouldn't
answer they wouldn't be in can you not
speak for him it's not a puppet show
it's not a puppet show L it's not a
puppet show he's allowed to answer for
himself of course he is let him answer
the reality is let him answer reality
talk Jeremy you want to do is bully
people who am I bullying you're bullying
constantly there two of you okay one's
run the party in the country one's run a
major Union are you really feeling
bullied do me a favor do me a do me a
bloody favor let me come back to Jeremy
cor if I may without without you
speaking for me can I put it this way
would you get rid of her M can I say
something you can answer my question no
can I say something would you get rid of
her Mass L can I say or thank you can I
say something
thank you Israel claiming it is
conducting legitimate self-defense where
is legitimate self-defense pre-ordering
the bombing of a hospital knowing there
are children in it where is legitimate
self you heard their argument about
schol they believe that Hamas and this
has been corroborated by the way by
everyone from Bill Clinton Bill Clinton
is on the record as saying that this is
years ago he's on the record as saying
that Hamas five six seven years ago in
fact you know what let's listen to him
say it himself
hereas is really smart when they decide
to Rocket Israel they insinuate
themselves in the hospitals in the
schools in the highly populous areas I
killed myself to give the Palestinians
State I had a deal they turned down that
would have given them all of Gaza wait
wait all of Gaza between 96 and 97% of
the West Bank compensating land in
Israel so two things then we'll come to
the second part in a moment but he's
Crystal Clear Bill Clinton in 2016 he
was President of the United States for
two terms right that Hamas were using
Hospital schools moss and others
deliberately and they don't care about
Palestinian lives they don't care about
them they knew when they did what they
did on October the 7th there was going
to be a massive reaction by Israel they
knew thousands of innocent Palestinians
would die they don't care about their
people so my question for you Jer which
you haven't answer jery
dead already how many more are there
going to be before this is over how many
more holy innocent Palestinian are going
to be killed because of isra my question
answer my question a ceasefire means a
ceasefire that's why we call they are
not both sides right would you have said
ceasefire as this is the Israeli
argument back at you would you have said
ceasefire to the Allied Forces in World
War II against the Nazis when they went
after cities like Dresden and killed
tens of thousands of people in one night
would you have said ceasefire or would
you have said you keep going until you
finish and defeat the enemy that's their
argument there are war with a group that
wants to remove Israel completely and
kill every Jew that can get their hands
on now I've asked you repeatedly I want
you to rehearse everything in the Second
World War I think military targets
should be industrial and Military
targets but a lot of homes and hospital
as you know a lot of German civilians
died in the process of taking on the
Nazis so my question again and just
answer this question
would you keep herass in power it's not
up to you what's your opinion you're
expressing plenty of other opinions
aren't you can can you calm down a
minute can I ask you a question you I'm
Sor calm down a minute if you think a m
should stay in power calm a minute can I
ask you question well I want him to
answer the question can I ask no he can
answer it can I ask you a question it's
not a puppet show ly can I ask you why
would you say her go you are a very
strange form of interviewing am I where
interrupt shout and abuse your guest
well you refuse to answer my question
and he keeps trying to answer it for you
no I'm going to ask no I'm not going to
ask me a question it's not your show
it's mine and I keep asking you the same
question would you keep Hamas in power
what I said was there has to be a
ceasefire a ceasefire has to be both
sides that ceasefire will then hopefully
develop into a longer term peace well
you think Israel can do hang on a minute
you think Israel can do peace with
Israel has been talking to Hamas for 20
years they can do peace with them after
after October the 7th they've been talk
listen October the 7th was abominable
and appalling that we agree and you
think Israel can do peace with people
that did that I managed to get two
sentences in between because you won't
answer my question look if you want to
have a discussion fine if you want to
just shout at me that's your prog your
TV your show should stay in power listen
what I said was a ceasefire means a
ceasefire it means both sides have to
cease for it means you then now you said
that should have Master stay in
power it's actually you're done it's
actually a critical question done it's a
critical question are you done yet no
it's the question are you done yet
should they stay in power you done this
country says they're a terror group do
you agree and should they stay in power
listen I do not approve support or
welcome Hamas are they a terror are they
a terror group everybody knows what they
are are they a terror group look PE
peers can we have a discuss can we have
a discussion can you call a terror group
can we have a can you call them a terror
group is it possible to have a rational
discussion are you prepared to call a
terror group is it possible to have a
rational you is it possible come on
answer that question you answer it no
it's my show you answer my question you
are the areass a terror group listen can
I are they a terror group P can I speak
answer the question can I speak are they
a terror
group if you let me speak are they a
teror group if you let me speak I'll say
something go on then a ceasefire means
both sides you said that are they a
terror group listen I said that because
terp part of the process are they a
terror group
will can we go why can't you say it
peers can we go through what ought to be
happening just answer my question why do
you
think in the world are calling for a
ceas a terror group come on answer that
me you got your show you've got so many
opinions why should I answer yours when
you won't answer mine why do you give
out your opin opinions all day and every
day you don't like it backass a terror
group yes or no you won't let you won't
like it when somebody push back on you
what I've said is I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling and you wonder you
wonder why people think you had a
problem with Jewish people what is very
is your inability to keep quiet for 30
seconds to allow anybody to answer a
question on my show I ask people
questions
normally they answer them you shout at
people only when they won't answer the
question you shout at people all the
time deliberately not answer my question
P peers uh I've explained to you how to
get rid of them M are they a terror
group L of course the why can't you say
that hang on hang on you've answered it
should they stay in power but do you
they stay no they won't be in do you
believe they should they won't be in do
you believe they should they won't be in
do you believe they should they won't I
don't believe okay so you've answer my
questions I believe it's not that
difficult to say hamash should go and
they're a terror group why can't you
Jeremy Corin questions ask something
about the behavior of the Israeli Army
and the Israeli government why can't you
say that why can't you have a discussion
about how a ceasefire would come about
why can't you have a discussion about a
process for the future you know why
which brings abouty which brings about a
peace for everybody because when I
repeated it does not mean that the
people of Gaza when I repeatedly support
Hamas repeatedly ask you are Hamas a
terror organization and should they stay
in power and you are simply incapable of
saying that they're a terror group and
they shouldn't stay people will draw
their own conclusions they draw their
own your conclusions before me conclude
with this uh you've done a book on
poetry poetry for the many I appreciate
it thank you very much wonderful poetry
from wonderful people encouraging the
working classes to embrace and enjoy
culture poetry and music for the many I
love poetry can agree on that good thank
you very much
goodbye